today's episode of congratulations is
brought to you by blue apron this
october blue apron is celebrating its
fifth anniversary by bringing back its
top 20 recipes from throughout the past
five years as picked by you the blue
apron community your favorite blue apron
recipes are back on the menu for a
limited time only blue apron is all
about giving people fresh recipes to
explore as they learn to cook a new dish
after new dish which is why and many
people don't realize this they don't
repeat recipes within one calendar year
this is what makes this limited time
only offer so exciting
we'll talk about this more later on in
the show but try out blue aprons
all-time cuts from our favorites and get
your first three meals free with
shipping free shipping by going to blue
apron dot-com slash Congrats this
episode is also brought to you by the
cash app I don't know if you've seen
this but the cash app has done something
amazing they've introduced the cash card
it's a new black debit card that you can
design yourself via the app and the cash
card allows you to use that cash that
you keep in the app anywhere you want
now you have the cash app which is the
best way to pay people back plus the all
new cash card I'll talk about this more
later on in the show download the free
cash app or iOS or for iOS or Android
now how are we how are we all
how's the cult doing this is episode 37
and I know a lot of you guys have
listened to every episode some of you
guys are starting now and we just want
to let you know if you're a new baby
hello hello and welcome welcome to the
cult because that's what this is and you
are you are welcome as long as you want
to be unless you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up yo
you know everybody's a cooter a little
bit but if you know if you're if you're
uh if you're too much of a coda you got
go
and by the way people are like I'm a
baby but what's a CUDA you don't know
what a coot is you're not a baby
all right and by the way I don't like
describing what the [ __ ] everything is
but people have been hitting me up hey
isn't it cooler if this happens or if
that happens no a lot of the times it's
know like somebody was like isn't it
CUDA that you take that you do shirtless
videos for Instagram first of all we're
talking about my bust but no it's not
that's absolutely not coded this is CUDA
okay what does a barracuda do if it sees
a shiny piece of jewelry it goes to it
because it's a [ __ ] idiot it's fish
okay now if you are a [ __ ] person now
now taking a shirtless [ __ ] selfies
not Koda because first of all you're not
doing anything to out of the if your
shirts off and I'm gonna do a video and
it's from the bus stop I didn't do
anything
to make anything else happen that's just
how I'm living BAM that's how I'm doing
that's not cuda the CUDA is like if you
[ __ ] go to some this is the ultimate
example you go to some festival because
you heard it was a good thing and you're
just like ah cool festival let's go I
was watching this thing on Facebook the
other day about this guy who started
this unicorn [ __ ] it was called the
you what's it called it was on Vice it
was like a 14 a four minute video on
Vice and it started with the guy I'm not
happy with reality at all burning mad oh
wait hold it sorry I'm allergic to
Facebook videos Burning Man made me
identify as a unicorn now there you go
it's full blown kuda you know why
because you don't identify as unicorn
eek raise its free conch but no matter
what you're not a unicorn
okay so this guy's like yeah it's a
polyamorous thing where we go and and
it's so funny because they made this
video and vice made this video
and and they like and and and this guy's
like my name is whatever it is and I
identify as a unicorn now a few few
years ago I went to Burning Man I wasn't
happy with reality and now I'm in
Burning Man and I'm a unicorn uh really
or you just had a bad childhood probably
it's probably what happened huh
yeah oh yeah yeah unicorn or he prolly
had bad parents and then he's [ __ ] got
all these people and they're like he's
this one girls like I've been a unicorn
for like bye stop right there stop right
there the sentence is already eroding
I've been a unicorn for nananana let's
stop you right there what about hey
these people are dressed up with [ __ ]
unicorn [ __ ] whatever the how about
this unicorns don't exist
you're not even identifying with
something that you can identify with cuz
doesn't exist oh I'm a cloud I'm a cloud
how about that I am a cloud oh no no
wait hold on clouds exist I'm a [ __ ]
dragon I'm a dragon I'm a [ __ ] tea
kettle that talks that's what I am I'm
that [ __ ] thing from be our guest be
our guest what's the [ __ ] buting the
beast that's what I am on that key I'm
the tea kettle careful you don't tip me
out you'll get [ __ ] hot tea all over
your [ __ ] [ __ ] and feet dude so and
they dress up like [ __ ] pink and neon
unicorns and and they have hooves and
[ __ ] Hey Dude get a job sit down
somewhere type stuff out get paid
you got communal and he's like and now
it's turned into some sort of a business
oh really dude really so maybe you don't
identify as a unicorn and maybe you're
just trying to [ __ ] get money from
people hook line and sinker you sure
you're not a unicorn
just fishing for cash hi I'm a unicorn
give me 12 lux
hey Sam shut the [ __ ] up see even he
knows hey I'm a unicorn give me some
cash come on dude this is why you can't
trust these [ __ ] that go to
Burning Man people that love Burning Man
and [ __ ]
people that love Burning Man you lost
and you going out in the desert he'd get
more lost no but so yeah so I was I
don't know why oh that's cool yeah
that's a full-blown cooter and we're out
war with these people we are at silent
or with these people silent war we sit
there in those [ __ ] in them in the in
the same rooms as these people you know
maybe we'll give them a little bit of a
verbal shots or some [ __ ] but we are at
silent war with these people it's us
versus them and if you want to be part
of the congratulations called fine but
we are not unicorns okay we are people
we are anti kuda and we are a hundred
percent it's free concert we realize you
can do what you want we're not having
that though when I have okay
in the laziest way possible Lorne I had
Sam stop being a [ __ ] [ __ ] come
here come here stop being an [ __ ]
let's take your [ __ ] shark call
often get you up here come here cuz it
doesn't have batteries in it come here
papa
there you go now you got to see the
video podcast to see this [ __ ] dog
acting up
but yeah so anyway I'm not explaining
what that [ __ ] is anymore but
everybody I got about nine thousand
dollars worth of [ __ ] advertisement
for my pillow at last last time and I
found out that maybe the guy has a
checkered past so very cool by the way
nothing cooler than have having a
checkered past and then inventing a
[ __ ] the most comfortable pillow of
all time I'm sorry I killed 19 people
rest easy
I saw some mug shots whatever though so
I was in North Carolina Charlotte North
Carolina and I was also in Boone North
Carolina and I did a college show at
Appalachian State it's in the middle of
nowhere it's beautiful it's a beautiful
[ __ ] place and it's so it's so like
college townie and [ __ ] and I love I
love I liked being there for eight hours
I was there for eight hours
I can't imagine be it going to college
in a place that is literally just
designed for a like a college even
though it's beautiful it is as it is
like I went to NYU for one year then
dropped out cuz school [ __ ] sucks
balls but no it's all good I was in
school though for a little bit till I
really sucks Tyrells it's not donkey
balls but um and and in school system
sucks especially high school because all
they do is teach engineering [ __ ] and
then you never know what the [ __ ] you
want to be and all basically is dummy
done so it's all good but so if you're
listening to it man and you're [ __ ]
12 I'm sorry but also I'm not really
that sorry cuz cuz high school sucks
talking about so but you can go to
college and kind of [ __ ] single out
what you want to do which is good but
still kind of still generic and circus
donkey balls in Douglas College so but
anyway I I went to Boone North Carolina
to do Appalachian State and it was aw it
was really cool man sometimes you go to
these places and they're like very uh
rim not room it's not remote I mean it's
still a town and [ __ ] but I went to I
went to that area and then it was very
good like it look like it was beauty
like in the winter I wasn't there in the
winter he was the winter remember that
[ __ ]
when [ __ ] Jay Z did the the Unplugged
album for MTV and he was like pretending
like it was a spoken-word because he was
like what was he why did what did it
make why did he say that he was just
like pretending like he was like a
spoken word guy instead of a rapper and
he just says it was to win to like and I
mean my friends talk about that all the
time who was to win to and he was like
anyway hoes [ __ ] money this is not
poetic so anyway it was awesome because
it was a beautiful area to go to college
it but I feel like if I was I'd be there
for four years no you know and all these
things spring up and [ __ ] I went to the
firehouse subs to get a sub say how much
dude by the way Firehouse Subs clean it
up clean it up and put it on my
Instagram dude we get it you were made
by firemen but you know you walk in
there it's like Disneyland for firemen
hey just give me a sandwich you walk in
and it's like this place was founded by
firemen made by firemen the fireman
fireman fireman we have fireman hats and
fireman's hey we get it it's all good
and you get there and they literally
have pictures of burning buildings
hey are you trying to [ __ ] creep me
out dude what is this a horror movie I
put it on my Instagram and it's like
they have chips and [ __ ] and like next
to the drink machine and then there's a
[ __ ] picture of a black and white
burning [ __ ] house
that probably killed some family members
hey give me a sandwich don't make me
think I'm in a horror movie
I mean Firehouse Subs literally they
show they have pictures of burning
property huh gimme ham oh yeah pictures
first of all they're black and white so
it's like so creepy hey gimme tuna salad
hey I don't need to be reminded of death
hey hey let's go hey dude get pick up a
couple of sandwiches and get reminded of
death we're having a party
oh cool know right where to go I'll go
to fire house so weird we get it you
have a theme chill out on it a little
bit because the theme reminds us of
death or just show firemen you know it
was the winter so yeah so I went to
Firehouse Subs and ate us up and then
went there and then I posted it online
and then everybody was like at
Appalachian State was like can you
believe you went the firehouse sub when
you could have went to [ __ ] Steve's
or some [ __ ] like I'm supposed to know
where the [ __ ] the good sandwich places
are in Boone North Carolina the [ __ ] I'm
supposed to show up at someplace that I
would
[Music]
never be and no were the goddamn good
sandwich meat is so anyway uh I was
there and and they have oh so you go to
these remote college places or whatever
and they sometimes they have like great
[ __ ] theaters because it's like it's
not like some [ __ ] cafeteria or
cafetorium how about when they call it a
cafetorium hey dude when a couple in
some place cause something to cafetorium
I want to piss all over the [ __ ] cups
in there this is a cafeteria or nada
Toria worst transformer ever so I showed
up and there was a theater and it was
awesome dude it was like 1400 students
they were loving it there was a guy in
the front row and his laugh was
literally like this and it was so weird
dude how about a cafetorium what does it
say a large room as in as in a school
building designed for use both as a
cafeteria and an auditorium hey man
split up the money make two smaller ones
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] dude if you're a
college you have so much money period
people are paying way too much to go to
your school and you have the nerve to
[ __ ] make a cafetorium and then call
it that it's a cafeteria or an
auditorium
I'm not [ __ ] sitting eating some
mystery meat while somebody's doing a
play a hamlet by how come every time you
Google something like a cafetorium the
Google image the first Google images of
some guy in black and white it's never a
court dude if you google anything it'll
be like it'll show you the first picture
of it ever in 1910 some guy in a
double-breasted tan suit and even though
it's a black-and-white picture you know
that that you know damn well that suit
is tan cafetorium look look cafetorium
definition one of the first [ __ ]
Google Images words of the year 10,000
66 ass so far away ago ten thousand
sixty-six the [ __ ] does that even mean
was poor people even documenting [ __ ]
back there or just saying [ __ ] and
[ __ ] dude were people documenting
stuff at the year 10,000 66 or where
people just saying [ __ ] and then [ __ ]
dude they were definitely just saying
[ __ ] and then [ __ ] nobody had pens
and [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] I mean
they did but still did but anyway I was
on the flight back from Charlotte
dude this [ __ ] killed me I tweeted about
it a little bit but I was next - mm-hmm
this guy he smelled bad and whatever
it's cool but hey man shower up and he
was like almost Asian or something but
like not America not like didn't speak
didn't like I had an accent
I don't know what accent it was custom
racist but he had guys joking but he the
guy came by and it was like what will
you have to eat would you like to eat or
what would you have to drink and the
[ __ ] guy next to me looks up to the
steward and says you guys have I'll have
a smoothie dude the only thing
could do is this a smoothie dude you're
on a goddamn airplane you're 30,000 feet
in the air and you want someone to use a
blender dude what the [ __ ] is hey hey
bro smoothies are for the ground
this guy do the [ __ ] flight attendant
goes like this a smoothie he says yeah
I'll have a smoothie he didn't even say
do you guys have smoothies says I'll
have a smoothie
I wish the pilot eye or pilot I wish the
the steward went like this okay sure
all right all right well we're gonna
have to land so hold on one second and
then I go over thing like hey guys um
we're sorry but we were up and on our
way to LAX but unfortunately one of the
[ __ ] in the cabin needs to he asked
for smoothies so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna land obviously because
there's no goddamn smoothies at 30,000
feet in the air so we're gonna have to
go pick up a blender because this
[ __ ] [ __ ] asked for a smoothie and
[Music]
we're gonna go pick up a blender and
then we're gonna go pick up a whole
bunch of fruit we're gonna get mangoes
and we're gonna get bananas and apples
and pears and all that [ __ ] we're gonna
get protein powder and then munch ice
and then we're gonna fly back up here
and make that [ __ ] idiot [ __ ] a
goddamn smoothie so buckle up and make
your chairs go back four inches for no
reason at all even though that we tell
you to do that because when you're
landing because god forbid your chairs
are four inches a little bit further
than they normally might be for
relaxation we don't want to relax and
just just in case we get into an
accident or we swerve a little bit on
the runway you'll definitely get way
more hurt because that four inches even
though we just made it up and then turn
off your iPad's for no reason at all all
right cool we're gonna win and get this
guy goddamn smoothie I mean dude a
smoothie Hey I was gonna I mean I I
looked at him and then the
the [ __ ] guy the guy the airplane guy
he goes like this smoothie and he says
yeah and then the guy says the airplane
guy says yeah we don't have smoothies
and I wanted to [ __ ] just say yeah
yeah they don't have smoothies because
we're 30,000 feet in the air I think I
says okay I'll just have club
I'll just have sparkling water and when
he said sparkling water dude it it made
it like twisted the knife just say club
soda or say [ __ ] Perrier but when
this [ __ ] said sparkling water
hey dude you're 30,000 feet in the air
don't get fancy with it when you're
30,000 feet in the air be less fancy
you're not gonna get the amenities Sam
shut the [ __ ] up
but he gets crazy - Sam gets it when you
get fancy with it 30,000 feet in the air
my dog gets pissed so I did that and
that was how it went for a little bit
Philippa um that guy with the [ __ ]
unicorn though man he was like driving
me up Wow like he was like I just feel
like we need to oh one of the rules was
for the unicorns was a unicorn is never
late nor on time oh come on dude what if
hey dude what if I'm waiting for you
I'll tell you what dude you show a
[ __ ] you you're never later on time
for a congratulations call member and
you're not a [ __ ] baby anymore bro
[Music]
boys even if we can say I don't remember
dude by the way oh I got [ __ ] nine
plus hours of sleep last night and you
know what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is the
deal with that [ __ ] I got I got two hour
I got three hours before that the night
before then I got nine hours and [ __ ]
thirty
it's dude you know what that's [ __ ]
awesome how about when people are like
dude I used to have a friend or and I do
have a friend and he was like I'd rather
get four hours of sleep than six dude
almost rocketed him to the moon he's
like because of the sleep cycles and
then you're supposed to wake up when
you're oh yeah oh yeah I'll get six do
it oh yeah
I'll get six no why Moore's better
I'll get I'd rather get four hours of
sleep in here come the tweets well it
actually is better because thorium cycle
you know what lick Mahal [ __ ] bury
yourself okay you say [ __ ] for you
say [ __ ] uh four hours of sleep is
better than six hours of sleep get
captured okay
no there's rules baby there's rules we
have to make these [ __ ] rules okay
because people are out there sleeping
for hours instead of six they think it's
better we're getting that we're getting
them very much can't do it I try not to
be political in this [ __ ] podcast but
so much political [ __ ] has happening I
don't know what the [ __ ] else to talk
about do it
I love how Trump was like yeah go to the
game and we know they're gonna kneel and
then when they kneel [ __ ] leave and
Trump was like okay Trump Pence pence
was like okay like Republican or
Democrat whatever the [ __ ] dude that's
it's a [ __ ] like I don't give a [ __ ]
what you are what char's what chars
freak hunch be Republican but if you fly
to a Colts game nonetheless and know
they're gonna [ __ ] kneel because some
other guy was like hey man go to a cult
game and when they kneeled leave hey
it's a [ __ ] that's our VP
[ __ ] let me do a drive-by [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] you're in a car hey in the [ __ ]
mobile yes [ __ ]
dude
hope you got surround sound cuz Yass a
[ __ ] come on dude
you know this friend dude how you know
what the most [ __ ] European thing is
in the world is to get stabbed in Europe
and then [ __ ] hear of a [ __ ]
European how come in America we have the
[ __ ] but in Europe this [ __ ] is hey
what happens to the [ __ ] what happens
to that [ __ ] siren on the way down I
understand the [ __ ] logistics of
sound and how it works but bro what's
going on that's why we know that there's
some extra [ __ ] going on in the world
there is no reason why the sound should
be that [ __ ] up when somebody gets
stabbed in France or Paris that we got
to hear that [ __ ] thing that goes on
why is it changing the length of it - it
does do it in France and dude just
YouTube [ __ ] French a hospital van
what the [ __ ] are called ambulance or
if you're [ __ ] or if you're or if
you're one of the kids that I went to
high school with ambulance
nah I'm not high school middle school I
went to middle school in New Jersey
everybody called an ambulance ambulance
hey what why are you putting a P in it
ambulance what have you got in there and
there were just a bunch of [ __ ]
lampshades and [ __ ] and they were like
hey man we're gonna have to move these
out you're stabbed dude Google a [ __ ]
French hospital van and just listen to
it going on in a man it's like it's
turning into a [ __ ] trance song you
know Arnie nonny nonny
remember that song dude I have a I
definitely there's no way in hell that
that song is not the number one song
that people got raped - I don't give a
[ __ ] I know it's [ __ ] hardcore but
you know that once that fucking's or you
know what even tops it this is the song
that number one [ __ ] shouldn't been
pimping should be what was that one
[ __ ] what was that one wait that was
the same one I don't know what whatever
it was you know what song I'm trying to
do somebody out there knows I'm trying
to give you [ __ ] rape somebody during
that song that's why I maybe I'm doing
it and it's [ __ ] sandstorm and it's
making people bring back horrible
memories and I'm sorry but anyway skip
back to the [ __ ] when I got
sidetracked by the ambulance and then
skip track when I got sidetracked by
[ __ ] yes a [ __ ] dude when I mean
imagine being like hey man go to a Colts
game and when they [ __ ] Neil leave
and then the guy going oh okay
speech speech and I'm not trying to be
political and by the way whatever part
of your part of I don't give a [ __ ] i
straight-up don't give a [ __ ] okay don't
care don't care but dude how much
destroy Pence has that face that he
looks like he knows what he's doing is
wrong and I'm not saying what he's doing
is wrong or what it is like whatever I
try to keep politics out of this [ __ ]
podcast but he's got a face that looks
like he knows what he's doing his wrong
dude and Trump and he's just like okay
well okay
and when people ask him about Trump
pieces okay well okay okay like he
starts like that and he's got his Lego
hair so funny dude sorry for getting a
little bit political I don't think I
really did I was just kind of [ __ ]
around but uh yeah
anyway anyway texture ever stopped in
front of a newsstand full of beautiful
magazine covers to pick up the latest
issue of bone Appetit
or wired or people but can't quite
decide which one you want to take home
now you don't have to with the texture
app you get access to your favorite
magazines on your tablet or phone it's
like having a newsstand in your pocket
the texture app has gone beyond
delivering just the magazine itself they
made it easy to find and enjoy the
articles that you want to read with
daily recommendations exclusive
interactive features videos and more
it's very cool it's not even like a
magazine it's everything texture makes
magazines easy and there are so many
great ones to choose from and Hollywood
Reporter Esquire Forbes Vanity Fair its
searchable texture is searchable so you
can mark what you like and check out
back issues and view bonus video comp
it's not like it's not like having a
bunch of magazines around and you don't
know which one you want it's it's all
right there
it's normally $9.99 a month and you get
over 200 magazines but if you sign up
now texture comm slash Congrats that's
one of our babies you get a free 14-day
free trial
well I subscribe to just a couple of
magazines when you can have all of your
favorites on your smartphone or tablet
all the time for way less right now
texture is offering my listeners a
14-day free trial when you go to texture
comm slash Congrats it's 14 days to try
texture for free when you go to texture
calm Congrats texture calm Congrats blue
apron now this October blue apron is
celebrating its 5th anniversary by
bringing back its top 20 recipes from
throughout the past five years as picked
by you the blue apron community now that
means it's those are the best ones so if
you're gonna sign up for blue apron now
is the time to do it okay for a limited
time only they're doing this so blue
apron is all about giving people fresh
recipes to explore as they learn to cook
new dish after new dish and I've done it
I've done this and the food is really
good it's really really good they give
you great portions and it's also
healthier and you feel good about
yourself so uh try out blue aprons
all-time favorites by going to blue
apron calm slash Congrats check out this
week's menu and you get your first three
meals free with free shipping by going
to blue apron
calm / congrats you will love how good
it feels and tastes and that's coming
from me I'm telling you as Chris D'Elia
to create incredible home-cooked meals
with blue apron so don't wait blue apron
dot-com / Congrats blue apron a better
way to cook bling kissed I like knowing
stuff okay so then you can talk to
people you don't know stuff you talk to
people you sound like an idiot I like to
read but I often don't have the time
introducing introducing the blinka staff
over two thousand of the best-selling
non-fiction books transformed into
powerful pack so you can read or listen
to in just 15 minutes if you're just
reading you'll get through maybe one
book a week if you're fast but with the
blink estab we can get key insights from
two or three books on your way home
blink Asst gives you more knowledge and
less time that's why I like it get big
ideas and small packages Forbes BuzzFeed
in the New York Times and Lifehacker
they're all talking about blankets they
were chosen in Apple in Google's best of
selection for two years and the app is
by used by over two million users right
now Blinky's has a special offer just
for our audience go to blink is calm
slash Congrats right now to start your
free trial or get three free months off
your yearly plan when you go join today
that's blink is spelled bli NK ist blink
is calm / Congrats to start your free
trial or get three free months of your
yearly planned blink is calm / Congrats
now I'm sweaty now if I said I wasn't
sweaty I was lying
okay very sweaty and my congratulations
shirt nice nice blue you know shaking it
up with the blue you want to add a
little color to your life especially
because gang called out people will
recognize your called member if you got
the [ __ ] shirt on suam wearing it in
North Carolina when I was there people
were making me shirts William person
made me sure call it was an elder shirt
it had elder on it people screaming out
their babies very weird for people who
don't know what a [ __ ] baby is
but uh I got to go to France by the way
because I got to see how French it
actually is I always talk about how
French I am you know with my hairy chest
and I gotta go see how it is I gotta go
I had to go we need to beat a pastry
remember when I said I ate those I I
said on a few episodes ago maybe last
episode I hate [ __ ] so many ice cream
sandwiches I haven't had one since bro
that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
I've been eating sweets really I got my
body fat or my body fat down I got this
scale I got my body fat down it's not
like eighteen percent I I feel like it's
probably less than that even though it's
saying it's at eighteen percent that's
pretty good huh I don't know I I guess
we don't know look at us we're just
[ __ ] idiots we don't know but I feel
like that's good I googled what a guy
with 18 percent body fat looks like
pretty good I guess that's kind of what
I feel like I look like I don't know
look at Google at Google body fat 18
percent what it looks like Google Image
it my producers googling body fat
percentage and not putting eighteen in
there so one fire
but one firearm but it's all good yeah I
look like those guys kind of okay I
don't look like that guy that guy's kind
of fat okay I don't look like those guys
anyway um but yeah I got less [ __ ] this
scale doesn't work I mean ruining it
yeah alright so anyway it's like 10
maybe and I'm trying to get [ __ ]
ripped dude I'm trying to do these
action movies bro that's what I want to
do these movies are so corny out there
man they're making comedies and [ __ ]
how about these dramas that make it feel
something because the music is in it you
know I'm just trying to do some [ __ ]
straight-up action movie where I get
tied up and a villain is telling me some
[ __ ] monologue before he tries to
kill me that's what I want to do dude
I'll shave my [ __ ]
head and jump out of goddamn window bro
you understand me
and that's a [ __ ] direct threat to
Hollywood I'll shave my head and jump
out a goddamn window and I'm not talking
I'm sorry I mean film it put it in the
movie I'm not talking about like just
regular [ __ ] bro
how about how about Harvey Weinstein
dude that's like hey sorry I jerked off
in a plant and wouldn't let a girl leave
the room even though she had a boyfriend
here's a letter I mean how did we not we
knew that was happening hey everybody
knew it was happening and now we fire
him oh dude that's the ultimate one fire
as a matter of fact Harvey Weinstein I'm
changing a name to one fire um that guy
just I don't understand I don't
understand wanting to like like if I
want to go get a sub sandwich and I'm
with somebody and they're like I don't
want a sub sandwich I'm like all right
[ __ ] fine what do you want we'll go
there so how the [ __ ] are you like I
want to [ __ ] and then the person is like
I don't want to and you're like ah I
feel like in his mind that was just
compromised let's [ __ ] no I have a
boyfriend cool let me stand in front and
jerk off into a plant compromise and
then in his head they were like it was
like whoa it's trying to compromise with
her it's not like I came on her I came
in a plant it was nice of him to [ __ ]
like be tidy though and just come in
some soil look what the [ __ ] man so
weird so weird
uh I knew a girl that [ __ ] had a
meeting with him or whatever I was
[ __ ] dating her and she was like she'd
a meeting with him and then he for no
reason and I was like he just wants to
meet you cuz he wants to [ __ ] you you
know she was like yeah but she yeah I
think I she's like I know that but like
he wanted to sit down and talk about my
career and she's like 22 and beautiful
and I was like oh cool
alright and then and then he did me and
she was like yo just so you know I'm not
gonna [ __ ] you and you're like okay cool
you know
hey guess if that went anywhere with her
career ya know there's a drive-by no
'mobile I don't know it's [ __ ] it's
it's uh it's wrong you know but just
[ __ ] know what's up hey if you're
having a meeting with a [ __ ] 60 year
old man and you're 22 and a beautiful
woman he wants to [ __ ] you that's that's
what it is okay that's what it is but oh
really but only but involved is your
[ __ ] rump see rump is involved Oh
said some [ __ ] Jesus Meryl Streep said
some [ __ ] oh so now it's over you know I
feel like Meryl Streep she could be like
pie is steak and women would be like
it's steak now never even do it but like
she's like the closest thing to a queen
we have in [ __ ] America does she
float I feel like Meryl Streep floats
I love seeing Meryl Streep in a scene
with another person and she's just like
it's like it's like she literally has
the look on her face like oh you're
gonna act oh cool
I'll [ __ ] you up like that's what she's
thinking the best actors think that [ __ ]
I feel like I feel like the best the
best actors are like I'm about to [ __ ]
you the [ __ ] up in this scene do it with
words and emotions or not even emotions
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I'll play it close to the
vest
actors when they [ __ ] dude what was
the thing oh you know like how about
like when I was looking at the Las Vegas
thing and the guy was like yeah girl
died in my arms and no we were trying to
help her he was straight-up just saying
it like he was talking about a recipe
and I was like god damn dude he must
have been in shock or something but like
you know actors if they were coming in
and they were gonna do that [ __ ] they'd
just be like oh and you know and
everyone would [ __ ] hold him up on a
pedestal and be like oh they were so
good so brave hey if you're an actor
you're not brave you [ __ ] go build a
house what's brave about that about I
get it dude there are roles where you
got to [ __ ] live for three months
fine that's somewhat [ __ ] arduous and
you're in it but brave dude brave if I
ever win an Oscar or an Emmy which won't
but if I ever do I'm gonna go up there
and I'm gonna say I'm not brave thank
you and and literally moonwalk
off the stage and I'm gonna say put his
index put his index position dicks
[ __ ] and dicks as I moonwalk acid
disrespectful I just liked all this
[ __ ] jerking each other off [ __ ] I
mean it's good - it's good - hey you
know but it's like how about when actors
picked the role because obviously
they're like I'm gonna get the Oscar for
this you're not doing it for the right
reason
yeah but it's like Meryl Streep doesn't
do that I feel like Meryl Streep could
just [ __ ] play the shop of a [ __ ]
play play that play the role of a deli
the deli [ __ ] person we call a
[ __ ] deli owner and she's just like
in the home movies just about her
[ __ ] cutting meat and they'd be like
Meryl Streep Meryl Streep she just rules
Leonard Maltin
rid of the [ __ ] that guy's name is she
just rules raves Leonard Maltin The
Washington Post says she's a splendid
delight no one captures the human soul
like Meryl Streep raves the New York
Post what
senada mmm it's not even a [ __ ]
newspaper raves The Village Voice Meryl
Streep brings a level of humanity that
even humans have never had alone in a
room she opens up a new door to humanity
raves an elephant that raised that
rights for Village Voice Leonard Maltin
dude
how do you get to be a [ __ ] movie
critic you just around your friends and
you're just like dude that movie was
good when you're 14 like yeah yeah and
again all it is go see it and they're
like oh [ __ ] it was good [ __ ] in them by
the time you're 20 the goddamn was good
you start writing some [ __ ] [ __ ]
online about how good a movie is and
then people were like like you get like
100 clicks a month and like ass [ __ ] and
then all of a sudden you're getting
[ __ ] a thousand clicks and then
before you know it you're 65 and you're
[ __ ] Leonard Maltin and you're like
go see [ __ ] Manchester by the sea
because Casey Affleck just rules I don't
like when they quote when the guys get
like cute with the quotes like it's like
she's just spectacular when they throw
all the [ __ ] good words out the
window you know and they're just like I
don't know I'm a dad she's simply
bitching raves Leonard Maltin could
Leonard Maltin look more like a guy that
would take the last pizza [ __ ] like
cheesecake on set Leonard Maltin looks
like a guy that if you were going to get
a piece of cheesecake and it was the
last piece he'd like be like [ __ ] I
gotta hurry up and get that before that
guy gets that look at that cheesecake
heater dude [ __ ] even dressed like a
cheesecake eater
look at that outfit you don't even have
to google it if you think of somebody
who would take the last piece of
cheesecake just imagine that's that's
him he [ __ ] is in a mock turtleneck
with a [ __ ] tan button-down over it
dude hey if you were a mock turtleneck
after Steve Jobs era watch dude dude
it's like having the Hitler mustache
straight up Charlie Chaplin had it okay
then Hitler was like this is how I'm
wrong to me and then you can't have it
after that
Michael Jordan tried about [ __ ] 12
years earlier when he was on a Hanes
commercial dude that was the most ballin
ass [ __ ] I've ever seen when Michael
Jordan was on the Haynes commercial in
the airplane and he was like sure I'll
do it and he showed up in a Hitler
mustache dude that is the most ballin
ass [ __ ] cuz you know Hanes when they
ship when he showed up on the [ __ ]
day of shooting Haynes was just like oh
like they were literally like look up
the scene in Big Lebowski where Philip
Seymour Hoffman when when what's the
girl's name
Todd Tara Reid is like I'll suck your
dick for $300 and he's just like and
then and then Philip Seymour Hoffman
goes oh oh that was what Hanes was like
that was what Hanes was like when
Michael Jordan showed up in his [ __ ]
Hitler mustache to hawk underwear
they all went oh what Philip Seymour
Hoffman does right there right there
seven seconds into the clip uh-uh that's
what the Haines people did I'll suck
your dick for $100 uh-uh she jokes a lot
that was the face Haines made dude
Michael Jordan hey dude I'm sorry but
when Michael Jordan I'm sorry dude but
when Michael I don't even know how to
say this but when I it like in 2008 or 9
when I found out there was an actor
named Michael B Jordan I was like that's
that [ __ ] dude that that guy is
the [ __ ] you know what dude it would
have been only the more of the [ __ ] is
if he dropped the B and was like I'm
gonna be an actor named Michael Jordan
[ __ ] the best basketball player in the
world
like button then I tweeted it once like
that guy's name is Michael B Jordan I
think somebody tweeted back the B is for
basketball which is hilarious but that
would be like like if I had was an actor
and my name was Steve q Jobs Chanel or
like [ __ ] hey I'm an actor I'm gonna
start [ __ ] being mu I'm gonna start
being in movies
my name is [ __ ] Moammar P Qaddafi is
that his name
no more or Moammar no Marvin no more
Garcia you know why they named him [ __ ]
it he's a baseball player for the
Pirates right yeah you know why they
named him [ __ ] Nomar dude you know
why they named him Nomar his parents
because they wanted to name him [ __ ]
Ramone backwards nothing's more Latino
no more is Ramon backwards I knew a guy
who did that
I didn't do it to his kid his name was
Bob dude no more see ya and then the kid
has to grow up in me like yeah my name
is Ramon backwards no more no more
Garcia takes the bat takes the blade
[Music]
long fly ball
Ramon backwards goes for you goes for a
yard I mean come on all right here we go
I'm gonna introduce you to this new
thing called saucy I hate shopping for
alcohol especially since I don't drink I
don't know what I'm getting I've wished
I could have beer wine or liquor
delivered for a long time so I don't
have to deal with it well someone
finally decided to do something about it
and I'm thanking them for it saucy
introducing saucy the alcohol delivery
app saucy delivers your favorite wine
beer and liquor right to your door on
demand it's like lyft for alcohol
if you're in Los Angeles San Francisco
Chicago San Diego or Sacramento your
saucy order will arrive at your door in
30 minutes or less for the rest of us
saucy will deliver beer wine and our and
liquor and liquor to your door in two
days or less nationwide there are no
order memory minimums you can no
delivery fees no running to the store
you got the saucy app you've got a fully
stocked bar on your phone I think that's
awesome for guys like me
and for a limited time you can get $15
off when you download the saucy app and
enter promo code Congrats
that's saucy that's the saucy app
spelled sau cey and enter promo code
congrats for $15 off get the saucy app
today and use promo code Congrats square
cash longtime favorites here the
congratulations pod everyone is
switching to the switching to the cash
app because it's the best way to pay
people back friends family co-workers
anyone I used it the other day sending
and receiving money is totally free and
fast and most payments can be deposited
directly in your bank account in seconds
here's how it works
download the square cash app link your
debit or credit card select an amount to
send and type in a friend's phone number
or email address to complete a payment
they'll get a notification they've
received money that's it no gimmicks
I even had a random person send me five
dollars thanks random person don't know
how they got my information but they did
Square cash is better than the other
guys trust me it's the best app going
it's easiest I use it so let's talk
about the new cash card it's a new black
debit card that you can design yourself
via the app it allows you to use the
cash that you keep in the app anywhere
you want you'll get notifications for
all payments made with the cash directly
via the cash app you can laser at your
card to personalize it and it will be
delivered directly to you for free the
cash app team is constantly building
awesome new features so what are you
doing using the other guys get cash app
today download the free cash app for iOS
or Android now it's free [ __ ] you can
do what you want but if you want to be
in the congratulations come be a baby
you got do you got do congratulations on
the sweaty shirt
for some reason when they built this
house they didn't put vents in my
podcast row so yeah uh uh you know let's
let's look at this let's look at this
here we're gonna go to Instagram and I'm
gonna look I'm gonna sift through the
[ __ ] up Instagram Plus this is week
but before we do that we're gonna
announce the next elder that's what
we're gonna do we have a new elder and
look before we announce this elder
remember elders are true babies who
demonstrate an exceptional devotion to
the show and the commitment to spreading
congratulations and sometimes they've
influenced the show our elder is Dan
Worthington at Dan Worthington why a
while back he made this crazy flowchart
to help you figure out if you're a coda
it's super funny and definitely
demonstrates that he's been a true baby
since day one
let's give Dan a big congratulations
here and on Twitter and welcome him to
the eldership alongside the others will
DM you Dan with the details to get your
official pin that is not for sale and
your certificate that's a signed by me
um you're an elder now dude you get the
cool pin I'm walking around town and
people are like how do I get a
people-people DM and me I want to get
one how do I get one can i buy one nil
can't buy him my [ __ ] opener wants
one I'm flirting with giving it to him
making him an elder but he can't buy one
um so yeah congratulations Dan
Worthington III like you I like your
style
all right what we doing here I'm looking
at through these most [ __ ] up
Instagram posts of the week I got I got
a lot of these dude
[Music]
I've already done some of these do it um
here's here's one this is so long dude
this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like this here we go
ready get ready for the most [ __ ] up
Instagram post of the week
okay gunk I love that part just look
okay so this is but some chick and she
you know what she's doing she's just
looking it's what she's doing she's just
looking she's at a thing and she's just
looking she's at a [ __ ] outside patio
thing and she's looking out so ready
pretentious to make a picture like that
you just looking oh and there here's
what she says just looking ahead to my
future no you're not you're looking at
some mountains just looking ahead to my
future it's so bright and it is here by
the mountains so basic so far in by the
way to say that just looking ahead to my
future it is so bright and it is here by
the mountains these mountains signify
the challenges that we must overcome in
life we all have our fair share some
more than others but everyone's
challenges are significant to them and
overcoming these hurdles is a part of
your life journey dude you could read
that on a goddamn poster at the mall hey
you know what you're inspirational as
the mall hey you know what you should do
if you're saying these things stand next
to Orange Julius
hey you're standing in the wrong place
though you're looking out aside near
some mountains but you're standing in
the wrong place because wish you should
be standing is next to Orange Julius
where the guy thought you could [ __ ]
where the guy on the plane thought you
could get a [ __ ] smoothie from
everything happens in your life to build
you to mold you and to prepare you for
your destiny hey don't talk about
destiny online anywhere unless you're
promoting a goddamn video game it all
falls into place tell that to somebody
who's dying of cancer by the way watch
how much they [ __ ] hate you
all life experiences make you who you
are today cool you die in a cancer
you're someone who's dying to cancer
doesn't work when you when you [ __ ]
implement cancer and this does it how
about someone who was jogging and then
got mugged and beat the [ __ ] out of and
now can't feel the side of their [ __ ]
arms huh the choices you make or choose
not to make the path you decide is the
one for you each choice on your journey
is important I acknowledge poor ones
accept it don't hold on to it be kind to
yourself and let it go learn it from and
then to redirect you but hey do it what
stand next to Orange Julius we can play
the victim to circumcircle stances or we
can say I am NOT what happened to me I
am let's use to become use your anguish
to help others tears the fog the
confusion then uncertainty all
dissipates the research for happiness
the search for happiness kostas is
because ray is there right now right
that guess if she says this is the
moment or not in it you don't search for
happiness
it's the light inside you yeah you just
need to let your just look in guaranty
that
person has bad relationships come on
dude don't [ __ ] do that's the most of
[ __ ] up Instagram posts a week let's
look at through some of these things
here this is from the hashtag
congratulations pod Chris D'Elia babies
at D'Elia babies somebody made that
[ __ ] account for me love the love
that you made the count Thanks
what did you dress up for as Halloween
while you were growing up now the key
word there is growing up now that's how
I know this is a true baby because they
know that I don't dress up now cuz I'm
what did I dress up for Halloween is
when I was growing up I don't know man I
don't remember a werewolf once a [ __ ]
one time my brother's my mom said what
do you wanna be when you grow up a my
mom my brother said a cowboy and I was
like that's stupid you can't be a
[ __ ] cowboy kid just be a cowboy it's
not a job it's a lifestyle and she was
like what you want to be and I said a
werewolf and I meant it what the [ __ ]
was wrong with me when I was a kid
anyway I was a werewolf
and I remember werewolf one because
Victor I was the Punisher once with
[ __ ] my mom drew the [ __ ] skull on
a black shirt and then I had all this
like cotton in the thing that make it
look like I had muscles and I think she
price still made me wear a jacket but
and then I was one time I made my
buddies dress up when I was like 22 I
was still I was too old but I made him
be thin Hawk from training day we were
all ethan hawke from training day and we
all had [ __ ] mustaches on were you in
it
no and I have we had the JNF and nobody
knew we were dressed up except we were
except when they saw all of us together
they'd be like wait who are you guys cuz
we had on like jackets and [ __ ] what
everything Hawker was wearing on
training day and we were like we're all
Ethan arc from training day that's
probably my favorite Halloween we were
at a party it was so dumb we had like a
hoodie on and then the [ __ ] jacket
over the hoodie I probably of a picture
of it somewhere but I don't know any up
right now yeah there's still when you
had those disposable cameras but
sometimes I still get people coming up
to me said can I get a picture and I
have a disposable
camera uh I always go like this okuu
where's your time machine thoughts on
here's one from Dan Clarke at Danny
27:23 mm-hmm borderline changing but
probably okay but if that's your high
school jersey number like 27 or 23
change it thoughts on people who enter
food eating competition completions I
think make competitions like eating the
most hot dogs or hottest chili but yeah
I know what it is dude thanks as in
eating the most hot dogs yeah I get it
those people are weird as [ __ ] how about
that how about they're just weird as
[ __ ]
how about they're weird well I feel like
an Asian guy always wins the hot dog
eating competition it's because of their
[ __ ] steadfast determination and the
work ethic how do you practice that by
the way some of those guys aren't even
fat how do you practice eating thirty
hot dogs oh look at the pizza
easy there's this one right here
Kobayashi eating pizza oh yeah it's
kobayashi hey how's Kobayashi not seven
hundred pounds oh he's getting mmm
getting nice with it he's like moving
his shoulders and getting into it and
he's got green hair why eats two pizzas
in two minutes oh my god oh now he's got
red hair eating the [ __ ] that's his
hot dog [ __ ] I guess I mean this guy's
gonna [ __ ] do it how about when they
almost throw up also why is this a
competition like people are starving you
know people are starving and have
YouTube and can watch this and these
guys are just eating [ __ ] hot dogs oh
and why is he raped
they're interviewing him he's got food
all over his face
oh how about this person Alex Cardenas
asked me about the eyeball tattoos when
the chick got a tattoo on her eyeball
and now she's suing right I thought she
was suing if not let's pretend like she
is so we can talk about it she's gonna
go blind right
hey this is welcome to hide as a game
show is Chris D'Elia
is it welcome to the game show the
person we feel bad about the least
welcome the person who got a tattoo on
her eyeball and then went blind welcome
to the game show you made your bed now
sleep in it Canadian woman who got
tattoo on her eyeball oops
and my producer clicked on a [ __ ]
pop-up one firearm
okay well then hit back how about that
Canadian woman who got a tattoo on our
eyeball may lose eye is warning others
about procedure hey not to be rude but
you don't have to warn us about that
because getting a tattoo on your eye is
bad then lean in and then it's okay it's
one of those websites that [ __ ] when
you click on it it takes you to 47 other
websites and then you wind up on some
[ __ ] girl sucking a guy's dick or
like some bouncing titties you know how
come [ __ ] every like 9th website I
click on if that's interesting they have
an interesting [ __ ] clickbait all of
a sudden get a [ __ ] bouncing titty
gif in my face come on I want to learn
something and I got a [ __ ] look about
some pasty white girl bouncing [ __ ]
big-ass titties in my face now also who
watches the Family Guy porn who watches
the Family Guy porn Seth MacFarlane's
got a bit like what the [ __ ] when you
watch like Peter Griffin [ __ ] Lois
and it with his veiny [ __ ]
there's fam go to anything you can type
and go to pornhub you could type in
Family Guy and then there's Family Guy
porn who's watching this one thing for
sure I know who's not watching it as
Americans for sure that's some real
foreign [ __ ] that's some like you know
she exists or you know agents do it too
for sure cause Asians watch some crazy
porn what is that about Asians what is
that
like the [ __ ] throw up ramen noodles
on [ __ ] and that's like a a sub-genre I
don't want to talk about that cousin all
right that's so weird what is this
that's just probably out of convention
yeah don't get tattoos on your eyeballs
even though I don't have to say that I
don't know that's it we could probably
wrap up around now but uh my I just
thought about that why don't I just
think about that something I do say
anyway whatever my buddy Neal Brennan
has a funny bit about how [ __ ] the
girls talk about how they haven't eaten
anything all day and then you say oh
yeah and then he says yeah but and then
he talks about what they you know what
they eat all day hey made that [ __ ]
sound horrible but it's funny look it up
[Music]
so anyway all right cool
I'm gonna wrap this up remember to try
out blue aprons all-time customer
favorites and get your first three meals
free with free shipping by going to blue
apron com / Congrats I've done it it's
really good square cash have you
switched yet download the free square
cash app design your cash card get it
for iOS or Android do it now if you'd
like you don't have to for conch but if
you do congratulations rate review the
show please if the numbers don't grow
then this calls dead in the water dude
you understand trying to get to this log
cabin at congrats pod use the hashtag
use the hashtag congratulations pod hope
you're enjoying the video episodes on
youtube if you listen you can also go
watch me [ __ ] the episodes video up
video episodes go up on Thursdays at the
latest so you know you can stop doing
tweet me where's the video tweeting me
where's the video upcoming shows buy
tickets on Chris D'Elia calm Australia
Adelaide Perth
Melbourne Sydney Brisbane Columbus Ohio
Columbus Ohio will be a fun one I like
going to [ __ ] places that were where
I look around and I think why am I here
other than audiences want to come and
see me
Irvine California gonna be fun love
Irvine one of my favorite places to
perform San Jose Winnipeg new date
sold-out that show except for like
remaining there's like a little men
reading seats they're like one or two
but I don't think you can get two
together because you slept at Calgary is
on sale today new date Calgary go get
tickets like Calgary Winnipeg sold out
immediately it feel like Calgary or sell
out immediately so go now merchandise
constantly restocked stuff is in there
and then it sells out that's just how it
is
keep up with the [ __ ] supply and
demand there will be new stuff there
either today or tomorrow new new show
new new stuff every day we're getting
this restocked yuku to restock a free
conch man on fire watch it and then I
guess you can like stuff on Netflix now
I don't know but like it you like stuff
on everything now anyway we're
announcing a new t-shirt this week and
it's very cool that might be my favorite
one so for the babies so check back at
my website chris d'elia calm and enjoyed
you listening to me and enjoy talking
thanks for listening to episode 33 and
37 33 plus cert 4 and in my head I
thought 37 but I said 33 probably got
dementia it's probably coming pretty
soon guys alright man you guys are great
and remember if you see my producer out
in the streets on fire
[Music]
you